bonjour je m'appelle Frédéric kataye
j'habite à Saint-Pierre précisément la
Rabine des fabriques je cherche un
métier de chauffeur-livreur
j'ai le permis 7 ans plus précisément et
j'ai un véhicule j'ai travaillé dans
deux entreprises différentes meubles ici
sont en compte et meubles confort j'ai
le niveau BEP vente le niveau bep-v
compte bétonne beaucoup d'atouts surtout
avec la clientèle j'ai déjà le premier
approche première proche la timidité
maintenant c'est fini j'ai appris le
montage la réception de marchandise la
livraison je suis quelqu'un de sérieux
motivé aime le travail en équipe et
surtout conduire en toute sécurité voilà
je me suis présenté je suis disponible
j'attends votre appel avec impatience